the way the Ninja Turtles should have
been and a loaf of bread who can't
believe you sliced in its episode 22 of
IMG
oh hi can we have a talk this cloud
looks like a dinosaur this one's a fish
this one is the grim reaper we've got a
dog and eagle and a skater on a halfpipe
gif break cool cool wait what's wrong
with her pinkie
and when Kim Kardashian sits yeah but 60
years ago women knew the real secret
Russia crocodiles teeth though let's be
serious the key to my heart is floppy
disks woody no no no no don't get any
ideas he's just a puppy Oh No for this
week's montage I don't know let's do a
jhin's who look like cats sorry no no no
how about cats who look like Asians yeah
screw it let's do babies being thrown in
the air a pixelated orca whale sculpture
in Vancouver and don't let go I don't
want to be used on a but here's a house
warped and modified by an artist in to a
dizzying vortex of doom and in the UK
the weather harasses you check out the
arrows well don't worry she loves it
storm troopers 365 was a project that
gave us a new action figure scene every
day for a year they play Scrabble tama
Yoshi for wreak out and become hot dogs
and the right place ads can be awesome
here's an actual screenshot from man
smears feces Vaughn lawyer flings it at
jury and this is the ad that showed up
next
it but this add-on a for children Barbie
site well the only combo better is one
that happens offline geeky birthday
cakes are awesome but now actual super
nerd wedding cakes Mario and the
princess apple coating with
complimentary USB cupcakes and a
companion cube you don't have to murder
unless eating it counts or put thanks to
the geniuses at reddit.com eat some
pizza art black olive darth vader green
bell pepper yoda a heart some kitties or
just rearrange the normal triangles you
get into a shark on Facebook Jonathan
showed us brilliant wanted poster
placement and Tim Ryan warned us to
recycle or else nature will fight back
but I leave you today with Arrested
Development paper dolls if you could
dress somebody up any way you wanted who
would you pick and what would you make
them wear put your answers below and I
will pick my favorites Photoshop them up
myself and then show them off and shout
you out in the next episode of IMG
so get commenting and as always thanks
for watching
you